the reason that I'm playing Tony Stark
the reason that I'm involved in Ironman
the reason that I'm so excited is I'm
crazy about movies it's easy to to
embrace hopelessness when things seem
insurmountable you make more money than
any actor in the world this too shall
pass first of all I'd like to thank
Susan Downey for telling me that Matt
Damon was going to win so don't bother
to prepare a speech he's an American
actor who made a screen debut at the age
of five he's well known for portraying
the role of iron man
he has topped the list of Hollywood's
highest-paid actors earning over 80
million dollars between 2014 and 2015
he's Robert Downey jr. and here is my
take on his top ten rules for success
number one is my personal favorite and
make sure to stick around all the way to
the end for some special bonus clips the
reason that I'm playing Tony Stark the
reason that I'm involved in Ironman the
reason that I'm so excited is I'm crazy
about movies that's why I wanted to
become an actor that's why I can cry
watching Judd cannibalistic humanoid
underground dwellers I buy into movies I
love it
I see the fly I don't care if that's
Jeff Goldblum or you know I'm like I'm
in it they're transporting flies dying I
mean I'm a sucker for this stuff
essentially and I would say this to
anybody is that you know it's really
it's easy to to embrace hopelessness
when things seem insurmountable and yet
it is it's actually just a matter of
time until all the elements come
together for things to be alright I mean
I believe that you know most difficult
situations will resolve themselves if
you are persistent and if you don't if
you don't give up entirely and that's
what I never did I never give up there's
a little holiday greeting I've been
wanting to send to the Mandarin
I just didn't know how to phrase it
until now my name is Tony Stark and I'm
not afraid of you I know you're a coward
so I've decided
that you just died pal why was it so
important to you to get the role of
Ironman because you have described it as
like a fight you fought everybody off
for that right just because I had a
really good feeling about it and I think
there's things in life with like you
know relationships or with life paths or
stuff like that to tell you the truth I
felt like I just felt like it would wind
up putting me in a position you know in
this industry in this business that that
would give me more creative freedom what
it did that it did that you make more
money than any actor in the world this
too shall pass by the way I don't even
know if that's true I can tell you I pay
more taxes than I've ever met truth be
told I've never ever been motivated by
money I gotta give it to you man because
you just seem like such a normal guy how
are you able to that is my power talk
exactly that's what it is me people
believe you're normal yeah absolutely
if you start playing violins I will tear
this joint apart first of all I'd like
to thank Susan Downey for telling me
that Matt Damon was going to win so
don't bother to prepare a speech that
was at about 10:00 a.m. I don't have
anybody to thank I'm sorry everyone's
been so gratuitous it was a
collaboration we all did this together
certainly not going to thank Warner
Brothers alan horne and my god Robin off
these guys they needed me avatar was
going to take us to the cleaners they
didn't have me we didn't have a shot
buddy what am I going to do thank Joel
silver the guys only restarted my career
12 times since I began and
25 years ago I mean I really don't want
to thank my wife because I could be
bussing tables at the daily grill right
now if not for her
Jesus what a gig that'd be
I mean it's extraordinary you had gone
through a period in your life and you
talked about life stories and life paths
you had five years where your career
could have taken a completely different
turn yeah you had the drugs you had the
prison and you had the rehab and then
you pulled it all out of the fire so to
speak I mean how did you manage to get
from that position to this position it's
easy to believe that things are
gathering momentum and going into a
negative place I mean I think human
nature can tend to be a little bit
critical of itself and of its society
and rather than quantifying good times
or bad times or highs or lows I think
it's really just about you know we're
kind of evolved Apes and we think we're
a lot smarter than we are
but if we survive whatever life throws
at us you tend to get opportunities
I hope I can inspire other people to uh
to find themselves you know I'm still um
still serious Constance data becoming I
don't I haven't really achieved any
anything much yet you know I'm trying to
stay in the moment that's my biggest
problem right now is thinking too far
ahead or thinking about the past and not
focusing on right now morning
eopns danny is that the last donut with
red white and blue sprinkles what did I
tell you what happened if you ate the
last donut with red white blue sprinkles
little foggy on it but I think it was
something like raining down hell fire
that's right
and Here I am without an umbrella
I feel a storm growing hold on if we
don't play that back
I'm canceling a press tour
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Rohit Sharma asked me
to so does the famous entrepreneur you
have made a profile next leaving the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of the ten
clips had the biggest impact on you on
why what change you're going to make now
after watching this video super curious
to find out leave in the comments and I
will join in the discussion finally I
want to give a quick shout-out to Erin
Hibbert for buying my book thank you bro
it means a lot to me because those of
you who are buying make sure you email
in your seats for your chance at a
shadow in a future video thank you so
much for watching continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you soon
I like you're not seeing a performance
and that makes me question whether or
not I should you know turn it in or to
show you how hard it is to get to some
sense of genuine excellence yeah yeah I
mean even uh even uh dude I wanted to
say anything worth doing is worth doing
poorly
you know the Joseph Campbell's say that
or who was it I don't know someone else
that someone really smart said it to me
and now I'm making it seem like you know
I've retained it for years but um yeah I
mean any any time you get up you know
that's six ten in the morning and go to
work for 14 hours a day or whatever you
know I mean it's a labor of love even if
it's a you know a cheesy sci-fi you know
holiday picture your character at the
center of this film he's materially
super successful spiritually and
emotionally not so much bankrupt and how
does it feel knowing every person you
represent is guilty it's fine
innocent people can't afford me is that
on some level a metaphor for a
contemporary society I mean what we're
with to a certain extent what many of us
feel well I know that in Hanks instance
it's that on look I went and I did well
I have these things I have a Ferrari I
have everything was good on the outside
but we like the idea of starting the
story where the outside is kind of
starting to crack and shimmy just as
this kind of natural crisis occurs my
mom passed away this morning
is this the first time my mother passed
away or is this something you do on all
the cases you're about to lose Christine
well do you relate to that idea of the
appearance of success but not feeling
fulfilled on the inside ah you know what
I can say that Hank is definitely a
character that I played I know that
when you have motives to have worldly
things when you attain them there's an
emptiness on the other side I think
that's just a function of of spiritual
growth you know and because I've had
such kind of extremes of fortunate and
misfortune I kind of have come to
appreciate you know both but I think in
Hanks case and you like the material
success you don't mind it meaning that I
see how either one of them can can be
disillusioning you know because some
folks really love drama and some folks
really love having stuff that puts a
wall between them and you so there's
some implied status you know